we're here with Nathaniel from spoon and
stable Nathaniel is going to show us the
cool punch cocktail that he made but
we're gonna do a single serve take one
ounce of the cranberry cordial making a
cordial is like a simple syrup with some
kind of acid base that with the lime
juice so basically you're gonna be doing
a quart of the cranberries quart of
water later sugar lime juice just a pint
two whole cinnamon sticks about seven
cloves two star anis tablespoon of the
ground ginger teaspoon of the cardamom
you're gonna bring it to a boil and then
after that just let it simmer down okay
and once all of them start popping
that's when you know it's about ready to
be strained then you're just gonna put
it into some kind of bottle and let it
chill so one ounce on top all right to a
local stop - you bet it's going this guy
yep oh yeah we're going to grab the pr4
on dry orange Curacao we're just gonna
do a half ounce of this it's a middle
liner in perfect
a little bit of fresh lime via the
citric backbone so it's a quarter ounce
of the lime just a little - I'll just do
this one quick of blackstrap bitters
from bitter cubed we're gonna be adding
the Bombay Sapphire all ten botannical
'he's working together here we're gonna
be two ounces daddy for I got that cool
hand motion I mean all the bitters if I
can't find this exact bitter where
should I get something like a Angostura
bitters something a little bit on the
lighter end dump that guy what next
alright so we're going to fill our other
one you did not use you're gonna add the
dilution and chill the drink so it's
delicious throw it in a carico tin and
give it a good pound one two three pull
it up show it off make sure this is
empty what's the trick to pull this
thing off twist pot like you like
strength though you know kind of like
pull it up then you're gonna grab your
strainers and we're gonna fill it most
of the way to the top again we're gonna
be topping it off with the bubbles just
hold that there this is the segura
viudas cava basically you're wanting
something on the drier and you don't
want something cheap because that's
gonna ruin the drink but you don't want
something to drink immense evaluate here
we go guys Cheers
dude that's so nice if you wanted to a
gigantic punch like this then I'm gonna
spill over the bar here well I'm
shutting it off if you're gonna be
drinking with basically take your once's
and then turn them into cups you do 1
bottle of gin 16 ounces of the cranberry
cordial we're gonna be adding a dry
orange Curacao 8 ounces of this 16
ounces of water a ton still aligned to
we're gonna be heading bitters few
dashes in here at 3 dashes where's the
bar here's the bar if you want to make
this at home just watch this video and
repeat yeah that's sweet having as much
fun as we did a lot of plays have a
responsible amount of these friends you
put your hand in the middle just hold it
up or hit other sizes like that oh the
suckers just I'm gonna put it up